I love the vibe that I get from anything
that James Gunn directs that he creates
like an onset family but when it comes
to a Marvel movie I have to imagine it's
like a little intimidating to jump into
a project like that so do you each
remember the first time you kind of like
felt part of the family whether it was
because something he did or someone did
on set to make you feel supported and
like part of the team or something you
reached in your character that made it
feel like the perfect fit I remembered
actually Lee Pace on the first movie
organized a night
for everyone to get together at where he
was staying and that sort of made me
feel part of things but when we got
there it was pure Jackson's house
and then we got to watch a movie in his
theater and we watched after hours of
course Daisy movie oh that's great but
that was nice because it felt like I had
been invited and included because my
character was a little bit on the
sidelines and but they were nice enough
to extend an invite
um I remember the when I first met all
the Guardians was at the table read and
it was a little bit like anxious because
I was like the the Newbie you know but
they made me feel uh really welcome and
at ease and they're so sweet you know
and then I remember
um hanging with you for the first time
we had drinks and then we went to sing
karaoke or was it the same night I don't
know but we had like a lot of fun
together yeah we sang a live band
karaoke where you could like get a rock
band and we sang Nirvana
going for it
it's Guardians like
claiming to be Guardians little do they
know after all these films and such
strong arcs and Evolutions I'll actually
go there next but Karen because nebula
is uh Arc throughout these three films
is one of my favorite parts of them so
looking back is there any scene from
guardians one or two that you found kind
of redefining or reshaping the character
most where you could feel everything you
do in Guardians 3 being influenced by
that scene I would say like a
breakthrough scene for nebula was when
she talks to Gamora or has a sort of um
shouting match with Gamora where she
tells her she just wanted a sister and
that kind of really encompassed the
character for me and all of her torment
and how all of this anger was just
because she wanted her family
um and so that kind of
evolved their relationship and devolved
gamora's understanding of where nebula
was coming from which then allowed them
to progress from there still to this day
one of my favorite scenes in this
Trilogy and like just in the MCU in
general I think as someone who has a
sister and you know we grew up butting
heads a lot something like that means a
lot to see on screen Palm for you one of
my favorite new additions for mantis is
that she and Peter are really embracing
the brother and sister idea and everyone
knows that now from the holiday special
so what's something about your approach
to the character and the way she carries
herself that changes now that she knows
she has a brother who also wants to call
her his sister oh yeah I mean it was it
was beautiful you know it was like a
beautiful Bond and um
I don't know for for me also the age
she's like brings me back to uh to my
personal story too I had a brother so
you know it was like beautiful to to
shoot these scenes and uh it was really
cathartic for some you know in in some
ways I love the family elements of this
um I also love how how uh nebula is kind
of growing as a as a leader and emerging
is a real force in the group so when
you're tackling that part of the
character two-parter on this what is
something that you wanted her to have as
a leader that set her apart from the
other emerging leaders in the group but
then also what is something that you
wanted her to have as a leader that
reflected the fact that you know she now
understands that she's part of a family
and a team and needs to respect what
they all want I mean it was it's always
been interesting to me that she would
become this kind of caretaker leader
role because you know she's been on a
healing Journey throughout all of these
films and I think like a massive part of
healing is helping other people to heal
at a certain point like you can use your
expertise actually in this area that
you've gone through and come out the
other end and help other people to go on
that Journey so I like that she would
probably have that as a leader I love
that so much here's my new favorite
question it is overly sentimental I
don't care it makes me happy so in this
industry we love to give each other
Awards and that's wonderful but I feel
like nobody here says good job to
themselves nearly enough so whether it's
a scene in Guardians 3 or any other
Marvel movie you've made what's a scene
you can look back on and say to yourself
damn I am proud of what I did there oh
my God
[Music]
um
um oh
no but I mean there's like some scenes
you you when you watch them on big
screen and when you shoot them it's so
different things and then you watch them
with like the beauty of the music and
the other actors or the special effects
and everything it's just like you know
it all makes sense and it feels like
magic and it's the movie Magic you know
so that's like oh that's what it was and
now it all makes sense and it's
beautiful so I don't know there's a
Cuisine that uh in this movie with the
abolisks I was gonna choose that for you
that like I I don't know it's like it's
it's I don't know I think it's it's a
beautiful scene it's so good in that
moment like you don't even say anything
but you say so much without speaking
like oh it's so good oh thank you uh
what about you oh God I don't know Sumi
amazing scene I mean one thing that I
really like I don't think that it's down
to me that it's so good it's the whole
thing but the scene I really like is
when I'm with craglin and I'm sort of
talking about how I'm gonna tear Thanos
apart like a dog and then he like has
the necklace line that's really funny
and I just always really like that oh
that was so funny yeah I like both of
those examples I mean you kind of
cheated and gave everybody else some
love here and not just yourself
the scene like with the car when you're
trying to open it oh
the perfect place to drop the mcu's
first F-bomb because I feel like
everybody understands that kind of
frustration yeah it's so funny that they
would use it like it's it feels like a
Monumental thing and it is used in the
most throwaway setting did it feel like
a Monumental thing on set where everyone
was thinking about planting it there no
I didn't notice that he said it until
someone said oh that's the first
f-bowmen in MCU history and I was like
really I didn't I didn't actually even
hear it because I guess I'm Scott I
shouldn't hear a lot I mean the thing is
like also why is it a thing in the first
place I mean we both come from Europe
too so for I mean for me it's like who
said I say like this I use this word all
the time yeah and you need a release so
it should be in the movies too yeah but
it's great that it's in this movie we're
proud of it yeah
yes the way that I speak when I'm not
sitting in these interviews where I
can't do all those things I always ask
her if I can say the word too in the
movies and they always say no oh
I feel like I feel like mantis's day
will come really funny if you could have
mantis utter I'll let you say it right
here I haven't dropped a single F-bomb
or anything if you could have mantis
utter a bad word in a future Marvel
series or movie what would it be oh
oh my God
we we tried a lot of different words on
said and then he chose
what was it at the nut thing it was so
funny what nothing like something with
like nuts these are nuts no I was I
would just say uh something in French
okay what would you say nailed nailed
what does that mean it means
okay okay I'm gonna try to say that in
another interview now and not get in
trouble because it's not in English
um but before I have to leave you I just
love hearing people sing James's praises
and what he's done with this series is
really something special Co so can you
name a Time on set when you know
workshopping you did with James or a
note he gave you had you you know access
something in your own character or
reprocess in a scene that made all the
difference well I mean he sort of
famously gave me a note that unlocked
the whole character for me which I feel
like I've maybe already talked about
this I don't know so stop me if I have
um where I was kind of doing my generic
villain thing and he was like stop all
of this and let's try an impression of
Marilyn Monroe and Clint Eastwood and
that just unlocked the whole character
for me now I have a voice like that yeah
I don't know if there's like a specific
moment it's just
um
I don't remember
no it's like I know that sometimes I
overthink or like I'm like you know I
just like he just like calms me in some
ways you know so he finds the right
words to just make me feel like you know
and you know there's like so much trust
and then you know you just let go and
and it happens you know he is like a
different director to each of us I get a
different James poem because he knows
that every person needs something
different
um and it's incredible to watch such a
beautiful quality to have now I wish I
had more time so I could follow up and
ask what what your version of James was
for everybody
um thank you for your time today
congratulations